>> Tucker: AMERICA ISN'T THE
ONLY COUNTRY FACING ECONOMIC
PRESSURE AND SOCIAL VOLATILITY
FROM UNRESTRAINED IMMIGRATION.
JUST THREE YEARS AGO EUROPE
FACED ITS OWN WAVE OF MIGRANTS
FROM AFRICA AND THE MIDDLE
EAST.
THE GERMAN CHANCELLOR ANGELA
MERKEL RESPONDS TO THIS BY
ACCEPTING NEARLY A MILLION
MIGRANTS IN A SINGLE YEAR.
ADJUSTED FOR POPULATION THAT
WOULD BE LIKE THIS COUNTRY
TAKING IN 4 MILLION IN 12
MONTHS.
THREE YEARS AFTER THAT, HOW
HAS THAT DECISION AFFECTED
GERMANY AND MERKEL'S POLITICAL
CAREER?
RICK GEMEL IS THE CURRENT
AMBASSADOR TO GERMANY AND IS
JOINING US.
THANK YOU FOR COMING ON.
>> THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME.
>> Tucker: YOU ARE SEEING
THE FIGURES ON THE LEFT,
HILLARY CLINTON AND JOHN
KERRY, BUT OTHERS RETHINKING
THE POLITICAL FALL OUT OF
MERKEL'S DECISION TO DO THAT.
FROM WHERE YOU SIT WHAT WAS
THE EFFECT OF LETTING IN THE
MIGRANTS?
>> FIRST, TALK ABOUT THE
POLITICAL EFFECT.
THERE WAS NO PLAN IN PLACE SO
THE POLICY FELL APART.
CHANCELLOR MERKEL AND MANY IN
GERMANY HAD BIG HEARTS.
THEY WANTED TO DO SOMETHING
BUT THERE WASN'T A PLAN.
SO, EVEN CHANCELLOR MERKEL ALL
THE YEARS LATER AGREED THAT
THERE WAS NO PLAN.
AND THEREFORE THE POLICY FELL
APART.
IT WASN'T IMPLEMENTED WITH
HARDCORE SECURITY MEASURES.
AND FOLLOW-UP.
SO FROM THE POLITICAL
STANDPOINT, NEXT WEEK,
CHANCELLOR MERKEL IS GIVING UP
HER CHAIRMANSHIP OF THE PARTY.
THERE ARE THREE OTHER PEOPLE
RUNNING AND THE TOP ISSUE IS
MIGRATION AND HER HANDLING OF
MIGRATION.
POLITICALLY I'D SAY IT TOPPLED
HER AND HAS FORCED HER NOW TO
GIVE UP THE CHAIRMANSHIP OF A
PARTY SHE ONCE RAN WITH A
STRONG ARM.
>> Tucker: WHAT IS SO
INTERESTING WATCHING GERMANY
FROM HERE IS HOW THE GERMAN
PRESS AND THE CULTURAL LEADERS
RESPONDED.
THIS WAS THREE YEARS AGO AND
IT WAS OBVIOUS ORDINARY
GERMANS DIDN'T LIKE IT AND IT
CAUSED THE CRIME RATE TO GO UP
AND IT WAS CAUSING ECONOMIC
PRESSURE ON ORDINARY GERMANS.
BUT PEOPLE WEREN'T ALLOW TO
SAY THAT FOR A NUMBER OF YEARS
IN PUBLIC.
OR AM I MISREADING IT?
>> NO, YOU ARE RIGHT.
I'D GO SO FAR TO SAY WE STILL
HAVE THE PROBLEM IN GERMANY.
THERE IS STILL AN OVERREACTION
IF YOU COMPLAINT ABOUT WANTING
SECURE BORDERS OR -- IF YOU
COMPLAIN ABOUT WANTING SECURE
BORDERS OR AN ORDERLY PROCESS.
THIS IS NOT WHETHER YOU HAVE A
HEART.
THIS IS WHETHER OR NOT YOU
HAVE A PLAN.
WE IN THE UNITED STATES KNOW A
MILLION PEOPLE A YEAR GET
U.S. CITIZENSHIP.
WE ARE VERY GENEROUS.
THIS IS NOT WANTING IMMIGRANT
IMMIGRANTS.
THEY THAT THE LEFT -- THE IDEA
THAT THE LEFT OR THE RIGHT OR
THE MEDIA IS MIXING UP LEGAL
IMMIGRATION WITH ILLEGAL
IMMIGRATION IS AN OUTRAGE.
THOSE OF US IN THE PUBLIC
POLICY POSITIONS HAVE TO PUSH
BACK AND SAY LOOK, WE ARE NOT
TALKING ABOUT LEGAL
IMMIGRATION.
THE UNITED STATES IS GENEROUS.
GERMANY HAS BEEN GENEROUS.
THIS IS ABOUT WHETHER OR NOT
YOU HAVE A PLAN.
BECAUSE NOT EVERYONE IS GOING
TO BE ABLE TO COME.
THAT IS WHAT YOU HAVE TO BE
ABLE TO SAY.
WE MUST PRIORITIZE.
WHAT IS THAT NUMBER?
1 MILLION PEOPLE IN THE UNITED
STATES.
IS IT 4 MILLION PEOPLE IN
GERMANY OVER A NUMBER OF
YEARS?
WHAT IS THAT NUMBER?
BECAUSE WHATEVER THAT NUMBER
IS STILL GOING TO BE TOO LOW.
YOU ARE STILL GOING TO TURN
PEOPLE AWAY.
LET'S HAVE AN ORDERLY PROCESS
AND FIGURE OUT HOW TO DO LEGAL
IMMIGRATION AND DO IT THE
RIGHT WAY.
>> Tucker: ARE PEOPLE -- I
THINK THAT IS WHAT WE NEED IN
THE UNITED STATES.
HONEST ADULT CONVERSATION
ABOUT WHAT WE CAN AFFORD, WHAT
IS GOOD FOR YOUR COUNTRY AND
WHAT THE NEXT 100 YEARS LOOKS
LIKE DEMOGRAPHICALLY.
WE CAN'T HAVE THE CONVERSATION
HERE.
CAN GERMANS HAVE IT?
>> I THINK THE UNITED STATES
IS HAVING A BETTER
CONVERSATION THAN GERMANS TO
BE HONEST.
THIS HAS LARGELY BEEN
CONTROLLED BY ELITES IN
BERLIN.
BUT NORMAL, EVERYDAY PEOPLE
ARE BEGINNING TO SAY WAIT A
MINUTE, THIS POLICY IS NOT
WORKING.
THIS IS NOT ABOUT BEING
GENEROUS.
WE ARE VERY GENEROUS.
THEY HAVE A LOT OF OPEN
BORDERS THROUGHOUT EUROPE.
BUT I WOULD ALSO ARGUE THAT
THE MISTAKES OF GERMANY,
TUCKER, RIPPLED THROUGHOUT ALL
OF EUROPE BECAUSE WE HAVE SEEN
IN AUSTRIA WITH SEBASTIAN
CURTIS WHO CAME IN WITH A PLAN
AND SAY WE NEED SECURITY AND A
SET OF RULES.
THIS IS NOT ABOUT BEING
GENEROUS OR NOT BEING OPEN TO
IMMIGRANTS BUT JUST HAVING
RULES.
ONCE HE ESTABLISHED THAT HE
WANTED RULES HE WON IN A BIG
WAY AND IS NOW BECOME POPULAR
THROUGHOUT GERMANY.
>> Tucker: YES.
>> SO WHILE SOME IN THE MEDIA
AND GERMANY WILL TRY TO PUSH
THIS INTO SAYING YOU ARE A
RADICAL FAR RIGHT PERSON, THE
REALITY IS THAT NORMAL
EVERYDAY GERMANS AND EUROPEANS
ARE CLAMORING FOR LEADERS WHO
WANTS TO HAVE SAFE AND SECURE
BORDERS AND AN ORDERLY
PROCESS.
>> Tucker: IF THEY WANT
CREATE RADICALS THEY COULD
KEEP LYING TO THE POPULATION.